[Music]
hello and welcome to quadriga our topic
this week the German Chancellor's role
in the face of rising populism on both
sides of the Atlantic Angela Merkel
announced that she will stand for a
fourth term if she wins she could become
the longest-serving Chancellor in German
post-war history
she and her party can expect a tough
campaign she's under pressure
domestically abroad however some are
calling her the indispensable Chancellor
the last defender of the free world can
she can Germany really shoulder such a
burden with right-wing nationalist
populism resurgent what kind of
leadership can be expected from Angela
Merkel that's what we want to talk about
today with three guests who follow
events here in Germany very closely it's
a pleasure to welcome or recover go she
is director of the European democracy
lab at the European school of governance
in Berlin she says praising Angela
Merkel today as the only remaining
leader of the free world makes us
quickly forget the enormous
responsibility of Germany for the
populist crises in Europe and it's great
to have Malta leaming back with us on
the show he's senior editor and until
recently opinion page editor at the
Berlin Daily the Tagish Vigo and he says
due to Germany's terrible history
Germany strong pacifistic tradition and
it's polarizing refugee policy Angela
Merkel can only be a strong
international moderator but not the
leader of the free world and Friedrich
Stalin is with us once more he is head
of political consulting firm
Taylan consult and he's a former
parliamentary bureau chief of the
business magazine Beatrice volca and he
says Chancellor Angela Merkel's fourth
candidacy is a decision for stability in
difficult times but not a signal for
reforms or new politics over here Google
the New York Times The Guardian The
Economist all described the Chancellor
in the last 10 days or so as the last
remaining world leader of stature to
defend quote unquote the West's liberal
values is uncle amar Kaul being touted
largely by default because there's
nobody else
appropriate for this role or is there
something unique about Germany's
position and political culture well I
think there's something unique about
herself because she was the first women
she governed eight years successfully
you know third term so I mean she has
proven that she can manage power that
she could stay that she could circumvent
crisises so that's all for good and yes
Germany is an important country it's a
big country so she has a powerful
position also by this but then the rest
is I think by default because there's no
strong lead and France no strong leader
in Spain not even a government in Spain
for very long breaks it or UK in a mess
so to say Renzi not really strong so yes
she is one of the remaining leaders in
Europe who survived basically the crisis
years and I think that is fueling her
you know power and of course Germany
itself has survived the crisis years
quite well economically doing a great
deal better than pretty much every other
member of the EU British talen does some
of this appeal to Merkel and Germany for
leadership simply reflect this country's
economic prowess not alone one has to be
fair to give the credit to God further
who changed the economic system social
system in a way that he lost his job
lost was kicked out of the Chancery
but significant reforms to the social
welfare state and that's what we he
Angela Merkel lives on it is merits
which are not totally hers she continued
the policy but on the other end if you
look at our old-age pension funds
policies which exercising them they are
not very hopeful but it is a combination
on the one hand her personality she is a
modest person she doesn't dominate
others at least not visibly
and she always so tries to bring people
into contact in in in conversation even
was most difficult like add one from
Turkey she continues to hold up a strain
of conversation as well with Putin that
is something of her reputation on the
other hand
to the country's well-being and position
there adds up to her international
reputation mother lemming you said in
your opening statement that Germany's
historic role as the country the
perpetrated the Holocaust essentially
bars it from being a leader in terms of
Western values but couldn't you make
quite the opposite argument that it's
precisely because of Germany's
confrontation with that history that it
has developed a culture a political
culture of restraint of stability and of
great respect and tolerance for
diversity and openness all of which in
fact do make it a leader correct I think
both both readings are correct I mean
first of all there is this part of
history and this part of history is not
forgotten for example in Greece in in
the Ukraine in Russia in in many many
places in the Netherlands in Norway
wherever German soldiers conquered
different in France conquered different
countries this kind of past it's not
forgotten sometimes it's more forgotten
in Germany than these places this first
of all makes it at least a
responsibility to be as modest as Angela
Merkel is but to be the leader of the
free world and don't be included in the
free world the United States of America
Australia New Zealand how can unguent
America lead United States of America
it's just impossible just impossible to
you not even can lead Europe right now
in the state it is so I've much doubt
that that she might be the only one left
but the only one left with very very
little abilities to really change things
that keeps putting together and the
question is not whether she can lead
Europe for instance the question is
whether she should be Europe and I think
she should not I think there's a deep
deep problem and concern that first we
equal macro West Germany makkal is not
Germany and the country of 80 million
should have different political
personnel to basically run the country
without her at some point
but second the replacement by Germany
fixes Europe I think is just not good
for the others and we have seen in the
breaks of discussion for instance the
last European Council Bratislava who did
the shuttle diplomacy before the EU
Council it was Angela
who did the shuttle diplomacy and it
should have been tusk or it should have
been sold or it should have been yoga
because the eus those are all names that
are not everyday you commissioned you
leaders in Brussels so if we are
preparing decisions for the European
Union it should be the personal of the
European Union institutions who do the
shuttle diplomacy this was my point and
I think there's too much basically
sublimating europe by missus Macker and
i think this is truly not good for
europe let us just take a brief look
I'll come right back to you Mountain
lemming I'd like to delve in a bit more
detail into what we mean by leadership
and what areas are being talked about
here but first because all of you
mentioned how modest the Chancellor is
let's look at her own attempt to manage
expectations when it comes to her
leadership and I'm honored by all this
talk that says everything now depends on
me but at the same time I find this
discussion rather grotesque no one not
even someone with a huge amount of
experience can change the situation in
Germany or in Europe for the better the
German Chancellor certainly can't do it
nobody could strengthen so Angela
Merkel's saying there no single leader
can in fact simply turn things around
either in within Europe or larger or on
a larger scale internationally let us
look at some of the areas that are being
mentioned as ones where Germany could
exercise some form of leadership and
I'll start out with a very insightful
article written by the historian Timothy
Garton ash he called on Germany to quote
preserve the liberal international order
including hard-won agreements on climate
change and trade flick-flick talen is
that really all that far fetched in
terms of a role for Germany after all
this is one of the world's pre-eminent
trading nations it has a very strong
stake in keeping open international
trade and moreover Germany has gone way
out in front in terms of a major
transformation of
it's energy system which is intended to
make Germany eventually climate neutral
so also a strong stake in climate change
treaties so there is this taking climate
change even it from an economic point of
view you could discuss whether that was
the right move because in an economy
that is well established traditional
role all processes go on a long line
easier to adapt but not opening that
possible but but I think Tim cigar -
quote it takes the stakes - I on the
liberal world whatever is left led by a
German Chancellor I don't see any other
German position I don't see any other
European I do not see that one person
alone can into it anyway I think it has
to be a common of effort where Germany
is going to contribute the problem right
now is that is the perception in many
many many countries and the perception
is because many countries became much
more nationalistic as we saw and with
the brexit in Great Britain with the
election of Donald Trump in the United
States Polish government they are garyun
government developments in France in the
Netherlands wherever so whatever happens
for example in Europe and matter is
going to lead will always be perceived
as cheese following German interests
because that's that's right now the
narrative everything is seen in the
world that the leader who tries to to
bring in some interest and to keep
things together let's imagine marine
lepen will be President of France she
will without any doubt say Merkel just
follows German interest and that's why
we have to fight the European Union at
some point back because you know now we
are celebrating sort of Maca less the
remaining leader of the world and she's
the only sort of strong leader in Europe
yeah that's for sure
the real interesting thing is that
before Germany became that sort of
leadership functional country we had a
dominance feature in the European Union
and what we term indominus was not good
for europe so in a way McAvoy's arose
before Germany became powers yeah and I
think this when we are now talking that
we have this threat of frightening
populism you mentioned marine lepen in
France and perhaps mr. Hoffa an Austrian
zone so foreskins
Poland Hungary then that we also need to
say that in the years between the
banking crisis he has 2010 to 2015 or so
it was pretty much the German dominance
in the structures of the European Union
which is cool responsible for what we
produced in terms of right-wing populism
and so now saying that Mackel is
basically the only remaining leader is a
little bit irony of history too so also
in the refugee crisis you know I mean
there was a huge amount of refugees I
was in favor of this just to say this
but it was also German decision to take
the refugees it wasn't consulted on the
European level we did that basically a
German decision and then we are
wondering than the other countries are
not solid Arian and the and other
countries turned sort of populism
against the refugees so I think there's
also consequence and causes and some of
the causes which now make feel that
Mackel is the remaining leader where
causes for which Germany takes
co-responsibility Swedish steel and
restraint and modesty are all very well
but the fact is in the face of rising
right-wing nationalist populism do you
truly not think that your country needs
to get out there and stand up for the
values that you our Constitution and
that your rule of law represent I kind
of you're all three of you saying no
this isn't a role for no no the role is
the role is not taking on the leadership
for all the others but defend your
position the rule of law democracy
everything to it that's okay but there's
some more work to be done first this
country spends 1.2 percent of his gross
national product for defense even though
they have agreed in Europe and as the
British and the French and even the
United States even more spent 2 percent
of their GDP and I think that's one
point to come back to and my apart from
modesty of I think a strong role lies in
that of certain internal politics
she must change projects inside we
living from the benefits of social
democratic change reform and from the
fact there live nicely we spend much
less on defense but that is
come back to domestic politics but let's
stay with that topic of Defense because
this is an area mantel aiming well where
European Union leaders are now scurrying
to say Oh in the wake of Donald Trump's
election we absolutely must do more and
Germany several not only Angela Merkel
but also the finance minister who's been
so eager to save money has said we will
go up to that two percent of our GDP on
military expenditures this is something
we must do do you think German
leadership can really count here in the
security area I don't know if that
should be the criteria for German
leadership if you spend 1.2 1.4 1.6
percent of your GDP for defense measures
this is not I mean this is not defined
this is not the defining moment for
leadership and you're right Merkel is
the by far the most experienced leader
in world affairs concerning the liberal
of the free world if we say it 11 years
is quite a lot she knows every agreement
by heart she is very very knowledgeable
and she's the one who should take over
the role maybe I didn't put that much
clearly enough she she is in the
position to defend the free world but
but there are a lot of limits she can't
play this card quite a lot but there is
no one else so and she for sure should
should claim the values the Western
values the right the right of law the
freedom of speech freedom of religion
all these things and she made it very
clearly after Donald Trump was elected
by writing this little note yes I will
work with you together on the basis of
this and this and this and then she
mentioned all the values she's going to
defend it may at one point I didn't
define the leadership role on the fact
how much money we spent but if you want
to be a leading person in foreign policy
in a Western Union or Western world
combination you have to come up with the
same amount of expenses as the other
states Baltic states are playing more
than 2% no one of them is leading the
free world
to meet these expectations to be a
leader let me give the floor to two
issues open here or thickener well
perhaps you would comment briefly on
both the first one security there's an
idea that Donald Trump may to some
degree if not entirely reduced the u.s.
role in NATO
hence the great interest in the EU to
increase European countries cooperation
on security issues
is there a leadership role there for the
Chancellor and number two values so yes
there is a leadership role for the
chancel and for Germany in the security
business obviously but the other thing
is how can it work and if it only works
that we cite which the French for
instance because there's now a
franco-german peyto on defense not that
I don't like this I like this is always
the franco-german engine but don't
forget Poland for instance take the
Minsk agreements we do a franco-german
cooperation on Minsk agreements we don't
ask the poles although we talk about the
Vimal triangle the poles don't feel
happy if you decide something on Ukraine
in a franco-german setting so the
leadership also comes at the disguise
that there is always sort of Germany
decides with whom she talks to and this
is not good so if we are talking
security then we need to talk about
European security and then it come it
cannot come in the sort of classical
formation of franco-german settings or
so and I think that's the first point
the second about values on values I'm
very fine to hear Germany we will defend
the rule of law what mr. Tian said all
this is fine obviously I agree but you
also need then to do politics which are
basically shooting people and this is
not only this is also the I mean the the
at the origin of European right-wing
populism is also a dramatic
mismanagement of the euro crisis and the
consequences of the euro crisis and
there has been austerity policy
austerity policy was not good who was
not good for Portugal for Spain for
Greece and sones of course was not good
for France so now to complain that we
have this right-wing populism and say Oh
mrs. mekinese to assure the values could
have also saying could we have done a
better policy on the euro mismanagement
perhaps he wouldn't have to deal with
the right-wing populism and we would not
need to celebrate Mackel as the only
remaining leader you know that's the
circle I would like to Swedish
may I just ask you also on this subject
of values as mentioned by Moulton
Leeming when the Chancellor
congratulated Donald Trump on his
victory she did so with the statement
that essentially laid out the democratic
values on the basis of which that
cooperation could occur some people said
that was an absolute diplomatic masterly
stroke to essentially define the
parameters and remind him of important
values other says it's absolutely
condescending what do you say I think
defense of her position in Germany if
she congratulate the new President of
the United States elect and there is a
lot of well critique of mr. Trump she
then follows what she has do as a
Western leader as it does in
international work she congratulate and
puts a little bracket around it
I only congratulate if you do these
politics that's the self defense in
Germany or Europe and it was being
unpolite and without being a non
diplomatic and there was a brilliant I
think you know I didn't deny he did it
and let us not forget how very closely
she worked with Donald Trump's
predecessor the still President Barrack
Obama
in fact he was here in Berlin after the
election and had this to say about the
Chancellor if I were here and our German
and I had a vote I might support
he's so he says Ulrika give ho that he
would vote for her if he were a German
but he then went on to say however I'm
not sure if it would hurt or help her
the implication being of course that
praise from abroad might not do where
any good
here at home what do you think Angela
Merkel in the face of right-wing
populism here in Germany
how strong are her chances that she
actually can win the next election at
the head of the CDU I think the
elections are quite open I think that we
are not even sure which coalition she
might prefer they have talked about you
know black green coalition there's talk
about grand coalition there's a lot of
possibilities I think the German
elections will largely depend on a very
busy election year between now and the
German elections there's first Austrian
elections was possibly a riping push in
Austria there's an Italian referenda
which is not a tiny thing and it's a
question about recapitalization of
Italian banks there's a Dutch election
there's a very important French election
and I think all these results altogether
will impact on how the situation will be
in next fall when Germany were vote so
can she win or not will largely depend
on what happens between and I wouldn't
say I don't have a crystal ball here but
if things go wrong say in France and
against my conviction marine lepen
should win for whatever reasons because
today everything comes at a surprise
Trump could win breaks it could happen
although we thought it could never
happen so we don't know and if there's
that push and it continues that we have
this wave of right and populism I
wouldn't exclude that we have a high
score of the so-called
alternative for Germany 20 24 percent 25
percent and then it changes basically
the balance in the party system but
allow me one reason for Hillary
Clinton's lack of popularity was the
perception that she was an absolute
fixture on the political stream as a
member of the mainstream political elite
basically for decades couldn't one make
the same argument about the Chancellor
couldn't that work to her detriment
there are some similarities I would
agree there but I would add the
development until the next election is
you have something new now and world
politics this is we had in that when the
GDR still was existing there was the
phrase
the real existing socialism it's not
socialism as we dream about that the
real existing one with the gulag with a
wall and everything else now we have the
real existing populism with Donald Trump
and the brexit and Great Britain so and
the mess this is going to create will
work as a deterrent as I hope to many
many people and maybe the simple message
either you you vote for this kind of
chaos populist chaos that you see in the
United States and Great Britain or for
some simple things like stability and
continuity and what is your choice the
big deterrence is Great Britain and many
Britons are regretting the voice for
brexit the next deterrent is United
States you can't compare the United
States with Hungary opponent so this
example and what happens the United
States well it's my prediction will
surely be a kind of deterrent
readers talen do you think that Germany
is in at least some degree immune to the
kind of anti elitism sweeping the rest
of Europe perhaps in part because of
that historical experience I wouldn't
exclude that especially to the
right-wing there are well 12 years those
from 93 to San 1945 which are an
exclusion to this I mean there might be
and I think it's too easy to they're
they're all right wing there whatever
maybe 10 percent represent but that
doesn't change the outcome the CDU and
nobody will deny here will be the
strongest part in any case the
Chancellor's party will this be
seong-chil and she sort of calmed
internal obstacle I host day of the
leader of the CSU's the southern wing of
the CDO he is with her so she is in in
if he is in a position to choose and my
personal conviction will end up whatever
happens around in a great coalition
because the stronger the threats from
the outside the more people in the other
to say let's take to what we have
stability don't
fathered around and even the SPD going
into a coalition bed together with the
ex-communist a linker who's part of them
do not want to be member of NATO part of
them objects EU policies the SPD is not
going with this part if the linker had
some very strong yesterday Donald let me
just ask because we're almost at the end
of our time ago whether you would agree
with that
we do in fact see a new trend toward
very hard right wing media bright art
the website that in many ways helped
generate much of the support for Donald
Trump now saying it's going to open a
website here in Germany in time for the
election could that change the calculus
older Germans remember the dangers of
right-wing populism but how about
younger ones and we have rice burger and
we have citizens who do not respect the
order of the bundesrepublik so I think
those in the gates in Germany towards
right-wing populism are often lately but
they are also opening the other
countries came first but I think there's
no barrage in Germany and I think
there's a trend and we need to be very
careful also in this country so for all
of you very quick last question fourth
term for Angela Merkel as a bulwark of
democracy yes or no yes yes
yes okay consensus all along the line
many thanks to all of you for being with
us and many thanks to you out there for
tuning
[Music]
you